parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans et qui
vibre votre magazine sur l'environnement
tout de suite le sommaire de votre
émission à guyancourt une visite de
l'étang des routières étaient organisées
l'occasion d'en apprendre un peu plus
sur les hydroliennes qui pelote sont
étendues d'eau nous partirons ensuite
aux mureaux où depuis 2000 blouses six
quartiers sont réhabilités en haute
qualité environnementale
mais tout de suite direction la réserve
naturelle de saint quentin pour une
visite guidée avec johan anglade garnier
conservatrice des lieux elodie moines
pour les images pascal josèphe pour le
montage
merci
pour cette découverte de la réserve
naturelle de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est johan anglade garnier
conservatrice des lieux qui nous dit dès
le long d 1,6 km de sentiers au milieu
de la faune sauvage créé en 1986 elle
s'étale autour de l'étang de saint
quentin dont le roi louis xiv se servait
il ya 300 ans pour alimenter les jeux
d'eau au château de versailles
zone de protection des oiseaux depuis
2003 la réserve accueille aujourd'hui
près de 230 espèces pour ces volatiles
l'endroit joue plusieurs rôles escale
migratoire sites d'hivernage et berceau
de leur reproduction des oiseaux qu'il
est possible d'approcher grâce aux
observatoire ornithologique
silence il ne faut pas les effrayer
lancement pas dûment brusque pas croyez
bizarre
pas les effrayer tout ça
j'aurais vraiment tout près des réseaux
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut observer en
particulier
je vois des petits oiseaux là qui se
balade le long du rivage à corps il
s'appelle cela alors cela c'est ce sont
des chevets les lignes est donc on
attend chacun est vraiment leur passage
au printemps et à l'automne puisque ce
sont des oiseaux qui appartiennent au
groupe des limicoles et qui viennent se
nourrir dans les vases exondée c'est à
dire que le niveau de l'eau baisse faire
paraître les vases du fonds et dans ces
vases
reste piégé des insectes des mollusques
des petits crustacés et il s'en nourrit
donc sa forme avec même si les petits
hélas un grand bec des grandes pattes et
ça lui permet vraiment d'aller chercher
cette nourriture et la gauche en fait à
côté des petits mots me justement je
vois des oiseaux des plus gros oiseau
pour le coup avec rémy allons coller
noir pour le coup et effectivement ils
n'ont rien à voir grosse oiseaux le
public qui vient sur la base de loisirs
en général le connais bien puisque c'est
la bernache du canada un très bel oiseau
a l'impression qu'ils par une migration
vous le pouvez le voir en vol les faits
le forme de v classique des oies mais en
fait il ne migrent plus en tant que tel
puisque c'est un oiseau qui initialement
donc au canada il a été introduit en
france pour sa beauté et depuis il se
plaît ici reproduit la prédation sur cet
oiseau est limitée par les autres
espèces si bien qu' ils profitent
las d'être avec nous donc il se déplace
d'un plan d'eau à un autre et en ce
moment vous pouvez voir il a déjà les
naissances
souhaité qu'il soit là les petits vers
la shdm qui sont très mignons d'ailleurs
et la mère s'occupe bien oui ce sont
vraiment deux on va dire de bonnes mères
dans le sens sur une passe du temps avec
leur leur jeune et si certains jeunes se
retrouvent orphelins n'hésite pas à les
accueillir à les prendre avec
mais
bon
voilà donc ces palissades elles nous
servent en fait
toujours à faire les suivis
scientifiques à
johan je profite de ce petit arrêt au
aux palissades pour faire un petit point
avec vous sur le fonctionnement de cette
réserve naturelle déjà chez qui un
règlement qui est très précis au sein
même de cette réserve naturelle oui
c'est donc c'est un règlement
en fait la réserve naturelle est un
espace de nature protégée par la loi et
donc pour chaque réserve naturelle vous
avez en tout cas les réserves naturelles
nationales décret ministériel qui donne
les règles de vie dans cette réserve
naturelle
donc que quelques règles et on ne peut
pas naviguer on ne peut pas chasser on
peut pas pêcher on peut pas jeter des
déchets on peut pas acquérir des plantes
on peut pas faire de sport et tout ça
fait référence à des codes de
l'environnement et donc nous on peut
verbaliser une personne qui
ferrait enfreignait la loi à ce titre-là
de votre petit écusson d'où les
questions police de l'environnement donc
on est deux gardes assermentés sur la
réserve pour faire respecter la
tranquillité du site ont fait et ça
patrimonialité alors c'est un petit mot
justement sur cette patrimonialité c'est
en fait elle qui conserve cette réserve
naturelle qui lui permet d'exister voilà
en fait c'est ce pourquoi une réserve
est une réserve naturelle c'est qu'elle
il y à des espèces patrimoniales des
espèces qui sont protégés elle aussi par
la loi en ce sens est donc
la réserve naturelle une réserve
naturelle nationale a une durée de vie
illimitée toutes les espèces sont
présentes sur la réserve alors pas
présente forcément à l'année puisque
vous avez bien compris que les oiseaux
effectuer des migrations donc ils
viennent ils partent tous ces animaux
sont libres de circuler dans la réserve
d'en sortir ou de rentrer parce qu'ici
c'est une réserve qui éclosent alors on
a cette impression qu'il reste dedans
mais pas du tout en fait ils sont
totalement libres et donc voilà donc
nous notre travail c'est la conservation
de cette patrimonialité et que ces
milieux reste sauvage surtout il faut
qu'il reste sauvage voilà on ne nourrit
pas les animaux ne soigne pas les
animaux on maintient les conditions de
vie de ces animaux
accueillante pour qu'ils puissent vivre
leur vie d'animaux et de plantes
sauvages nous on a eu la chance pour tv
fils de venir faire cette visite avec
vous oui je sais que le 24 mai prochain
c'est la fête de la nature et il ya un
programme 30 personnes sont invitées à
vous rejoindre pour une une belle visite
guidée aussi voilà donc si vous voulez
découvrir ou redécouvrir la réserve
naturelle venez donc le samedi après
midi à 14 heures à la maison de la
réserve et je vous emmènerai faire cette
même balade pour observer les oiseaux et
vous expliquer encore plus l'histoire de
cette réserve naturelle
c'est à l'occasion de la fête de la
nature le fait chaque année donc ce que
c'est pas bon cette année revenez
l'année prochaine y'a aucun souci vous
serez les bienvenus
on
dans le cadre des européennes jean marie
cavada marielle de sarnez et brice
lalonde se sont rendus à l'étang des
routières à guyancourt l'occasion d'y
découvrir les hydroliennes qui oxygène
le bassin jonathan wiedemann pour les
images
une visite écologique à l'étang des
rousses hier le 2 mai à guyancourt les
candidats udi modem aux européennes ont
découvert un dispositif environnementale
novateurs mis en place en 2010 pour
préserver la faune et la flore aquatique
deux hydroliennes haute de presque 4
mètres pour un poids de 450 kg flotte
dans le bassin et permettent de mieux
oxygénés l'eau avec pour moteur unique
la force du vent elles démarrent à
partir de 5e est paraphée 4 elle tombe
quasiment tout le temps et en fait avant
en dessous il ya une petite hélice ya
une colonne ou tiges de roulement qui va
entraîner cette petite hélice et qui va
créer en fait des brassages dans l'eau
ce qui va homogénéiser tout l'oxygène
qu'on peut avoir dans la colonne d'eau
et en fait quand les bactéries elles ont
plus d'oxygène elles vont dégrader mieux
tout ce qui est matières organiques et
on a constaté on a fait les analyses en
2010 2011 et 2012 une réduction de 30 %
de la matière organique avec ces
hydroliennes les temps qui date de 1978
était déjà assainie grâce à deux bassins
épurateurs et même si un boudin de
protection contre les hydrocarbures
s'est ajoutée en 97 les équipements
certes efficace avait besoin d'un
complément une innovation qui a coûté
presque quarante mille euros permise
notamment par l'apport financier de
l'union européenne tous les progrès qui
ont été réalisés depuis une quarantaine
d'années dans le domaine de l'eau et de
l'environnement c'est grâce à l'europe
et l'europe n'est pas seulement
importante pour les européens pour ceux
qui vivent dans les 28 pays de l'union
elle est très importante aussi pour la
planète parce que la question de l'eau
va être une question absolument crucial
vous savez il va bientôt y avoir neuf
milliards de personnes à la surface de
cette planète mais la quantité d'eau est
toujours la même et donc il va falloir
inventer trouver trouver de nouvelles
formules passé des conventions
internationales et la neuro psycho
championne du monde de l'environnement à
l'avenir d'autres moyens des polluants
100% écologiques sont envisagées à
l'étang des rousses hier la
phytoremédiation notamment utilisant des
plantes au bord de l'eau pour absorber
les micropolluants
en attendant les deux hydroliennes
continue de faire le printemps
au mur aussi quartiers sont en cours de
réhabilitation une réhabilitation qui
s'effectue de manière écologique avec
des bâtiments de haute qualité
environnementale jonathan willeman pour
les images
une rénovation urbaine de haute qualité
environnementale c'est aux mureaux sur
70 hectares et six quartiers que s'opère
un vaste chantier depuis septembre 2012
crèches écoles maternelles et primaires
centres de loisirs et ludothèque le pôle
molière proposera dès la rentrée
prochaine ses multiples activités tout
en s'intégrant parfaitement à
l'environnement
ce qui est important dans ce bâtiment ça
a été toute la question énergétique et
le développement donc il ya eu tout un
travail à la fois sur la construction
des bâtiments donc sur le traitement des
façades avec des systèmes de d'isolation
par l'extérieur on a créé des boîtes
isolé si vous permet donc qui consomment
le moins possible et qui sont également
le plus lumineuse on passe sur des
bâtiments qui consomment donc très peu
on est sur des consommations de
chauffage qui sont inférieures à 15
kilowatts par mètre carré et par an les
bâtiments passifs deviennent même
positif grâce à l'action des 450 mètres
carrés de panneaux photovoltaïques
placés sur les toits
le pôle molière produit donc plus
d'électricité qui n'en consomment et
pour à réinjecter l'énergie dans le
réseau public les eaux pluviales sont
également récupéré filtré via des nous
creuser dans la rue et le long des
bâtiments des aménagements écologiques
qui ont coûté plus cher qu'un projet
classique mais qui au fil du temps sa
veyron rentable l'investissement
confession un bâtiment doit se compter
sur le long terme donc là effectivement
l'investissement sur le long terme vu
les économies d'énergie qu'on va faire
voilà vue de ce point de vue là le
bâtiment n'est pas plus coûteux 17
millions d'euros ont été nécessaires
pour financer les travaux du pôle
molière lauréats 2012 du prix bâtiment
positif décerné par l'ademe les 6000
mètres carrés du complexe seront livrés
à la fin de cet été
c'est la fin de cette émission mais
avant de se quitter place à votre agenda
environnementale le 17 mai rendez vous à
la ferme de bulles loyer pour découvrir
la permaculture une agriculture qui
permet l'harmonie entre activité humaine
et écosystèmes
dès le 24 mai l'exposition la maison de
l'environnement nous parle des graines
arbres fleurs plantes et les graines
contiennent des trésors que vous pourrez
découvrir jusqu'au 7 juin enfin le
samedi 24 mai à l'étang des roussière
découvrez toute la biodiversité autour
d'une étendue d'eau une biodiversité qui
a influencé notre médecine notre
gastronomie ou encore certaines
inventions technologiques
voilà c'est tout pour ce mois-ci
prochain rendez vous le 20 juin et d'ici
là n'oubliez pas la terre est notre mère
respectons la salut